[Musique]
il est grand temps de vous parler de
masse kanata personnages secondaires du
film star wars cette masse canada
possède tout de même un rôle clé dans ce
dernier une alien âgés de plus de 1000
en masse canada est très connu deux âmes
solo et chewbacca
elle a tout vu tout vécu les sites
l'empiré maintenant le premier ordre
elle est même en possession du sabre
laser bleu d'anakin skywalker lui même
c'est un personnage important très
mystérieux dont nous ne connaissons pas
encore tous les secrets c'est pourquoi
nous allons voir trois théories sur ce
protagoniste que je vous propose
[Musique]
une question majeure qui revient
fréquemment depuis la sortie du film
star wars cette commande massa récupère
et le sabre de l'udc appartenant
anciennement anakin ce sabre était le
second khanaqinne à posséder avant
d'être récupéré par obi wan suit alors
un frottement sur mustafar ce dernier
l'a ensuite transmis à l'udc qui perdu
via son affrontement entre son père dark
vador
cependant le problème c'est que le sabre
est tombé dans le vide et nous ne
l'avons plus jamais revu et il
réapparaît dans star wars est dans les
réserves de masques anata la théorie la
plus probable serait qu un charognard un
pirate ou je ne sais quoi l'aurait
récupéré dans l'espace la base où l'udc
a perdu son sabre s'appelait des spin et
il faut savoir que cette base n'était
pas très loin de la planète de tacoda
n'a la planète ou maze habite et où elle
accueille dans son bar château de
nombreux pirates ou autres
contrebandiers
vous voyez où je veux en venir le
charognard en question est allé sur
tacot dana et à marchander avec masse
pour qu'elle récupère le sabre qu'elle
avait reconnu luc était le dernier jedi
et était donc très connue de tous seules
les jedi possède un sabre laser et masse
le sait très bien
c'est pourquoi elle la marchande est
cependant masse précise en solo que le
fait de posséder le sabre était une
longue histoire et se pourrait que maze
soit allé le récupérer elle même sur b
spin suite à la guerre
le sabre de l'udc anciennement celui
d'anakin est un trésor réellement
inestimable mazaurette alors braver de
nombreux dangers et pour chercher des
poux sur b spin carmat est considéré
tout de même comme une pirate ou
contrebandiers et serait alors tombé sur
le sabre
je ne vois que ces explications les
masses connaît bien les skywalker pas
personnellement mais leur histoire ce
n'est pas un hasard si cette dernière
possède cette arme
il édite le mas kanata possède plus de
mille ans maze a donc bel et bien connu
les sites lempire est aujourd'hui le
premier ordre
elle existe depuis bien avant la
naissance d'anakin si nous devions
prendre un point de référence
mais quelque chose ne vous interpelle
pas dans ce que j'ai dit mas a connu les
sites
elle le dit dans l'opus 7 ce que je veux
dire ici c'est que mas connaissait le
côté obscur et le groupe des sites qui
étaient un groupe plutôt secret tout le
monde connaissait lempire cependant peu
connaissait réellement la vraie nature
de ses dirigeants cela veut donc dire
que maze étaient présentes
je n'ai pas envie de vous dire de
bêtises car on ne va pas se le cacher
une théorie complètement farfelu tourner
sur internet affirmant que maze kanata
serait une déjà oit pour ceux qui ne se
rappellerait pas ce qu'était un jawas et
des petits pirates des sables y vivent
sur tatouine et que nous apercevons en
groupe
certaines fois dans les films cependant
maze s'occupe de son château depuis des
années et des années
elle ne s'est pas arrêté 50 ans pour
vivre comme une indigène sur tatouine ce
qui est certain en tout cas c'est que
maze à plus de mille ans elle a connu
les sites et l' empire les skywalker et
leur histoire
cela fait beaucoup non mazet quelqu'un
d'important et son personnage n'est
malheureusement pas assez des cris car
dans tout ce que je viens de dire ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que maze était
peut-être présente dans les six premiers
films en tant que figurant même si je
pense que le personnage a juste été créé
pour star wars 7 8 et 9
mas kanata ans s'est énormément sur la
force elle connaît son origine comment
la ressentir et même comment l'utiliser
vous voyez où je veux en venir
et si mass kanata était une jedi enfin
plutôt une adepte de la force
le terme de jedi ou de sites ne lui
conviendrait pas car elle n'est ni l'un
ni l'autre cependant s et maîtriser la
force cela a été confirmé par les
producteurs que masse devaient utiliser
la force durant la scène du débarquement
du premier ordre sur sa planète
mais la scène a été enlevé du film pour
on ne sait quelle raison
néanmoins je ne vous cache pas que cette
nouvelle change énormément de choses
mas pourrait alors avoir un rôle
important dans l'histoire de star wars
tout d'abord je suis quasiment certain
qu'elle a dû ressentir le sabre laser
d'anakin qui fut tombée sur b spin
ensuite il ne serait pas impossible
qu'elles prennent part au combat contre
stoke souhaitant et des raies qu'elle
affectionnait tout particulièrement et
qu'il intrigue est beaucoup on a
d'ailleurs l'impression qu'elle connaît
des jarrets elle essaye même de
l'orienter apprendre le sabre elle lui
dit même que ses proches ne reviendront
jamais la chercher
mas kanata sait des choses d'ailleurs
j'aimerais vous énoncez quelque chose
qui nous dit que la vision du sabre
laser qu'à subir elle ne serait pas un
tour de masse qui voudraient qu'elle
rejoigne et retrouve luc je vous
rappelle que mas associe tout de même
les proches de ré à luke skywalker un
autre pourrait revenir lui
elle parle évidemment d'un proche arrêt
quelqu'un qui la connaît mas possède un
rôle important et je serai vraiment pas
surpris de la revoir dans les prochains
opus
si certains se rappellent du trois
théories sur la fin de l'opus 9 masse
pourrait très bien faire partie des jedi
cacher comme des ermites et qui au
moment propice se battrait contre les
chevaliers de rennes cependant
j'aimerais revenir sur mon terme de
djeddah et cacher la force a évolué et
les jedi et les sith n'existe plus réel
massé utiliser la force en être d'un
côté précis et elle ne doit pas être la
seule qui sait je m'emporte beaucoup
mais c'est ce que j'aime dans mon
émission théorie j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura plu merci à ceux qui
penseront au pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo je ne vous souhaite
que le meilleur set et argo rock que le
lay honneur soit avec vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]